le 18 décembre est la journée
internationale des migrants l'occasion
pour des collectifs syndicats
associations d'appeler à un
rassemblement national pour se souvenir
de tous les drames migratoires et
s'interroger sur la politique en la
matière et qui applique l'union
européenne dont le cortège parisien
notre reporter un adage abderrazak ont
l'art font tout de suite
bonjour la neige alors quel est
l'objectif ans de cette manifestation
aujourd'hui
l'objectif de ce rassemblement amira
bien c'est de lutter contre toutes les
formes de racisme alors on est situé
boulevard de clichy à l'heure actuelle
ils sont plus d'un millier de personnes
à avoir répondu à l'invitation de
plusieurs organisations syndicales
politiques et des associations de
soutien aux migrants alors vous
l'entendez très certainement est
derrière moi beaucoup d'ambiance ans
dans ce cortège de la musique et des
chants et puis des slogans également
hostile à la politique d' emmanuel
macron mais pas seulement à certains
candidats également à l'élection
présidentielle comme eric zemmour
valérie pécresse ou encore home
ou encore d'autres donc des manifestants
qui est où je le disais protestent
contre toute forme de racisme mais qui
demande à plus de dignité à vivre
dignement je vous proposais le sujet
d'écouter certains manifestants que l'on
a pu interroger tout à l'heure
la france est elle accueille une infime
partie des flux migratoires a aussi un
faut arrêter de se faire passer pour un
pays submergé
c'est du pipeau tout ça c'est de la
propagande ne sont pas des délinquants
parce que quand on entend d'autres dans
les médias c'est comme si on nous prend
pour des délinquants nous sommes là si
on a fait notre passion on n'a pas le
choix sinon nous on voudrait prendre
l'avion venir en france n ont pas passé
par là mais terre-neuvien passer par
deux voire dangereux on n'a pas la
solution prend la médiation n'a pas le
choix on aimerait c'est selon dans la
dignité mais pourquoi pas
l'air du temps est mauvais il est même
carrément pour rire ans à l'égard des
étrangers
je fais partie des gens qui se battent
pour le droit toute personne de vivre
ici dans des conditions décentes je
crois que les étrangers sont très en
danger en ce moment en france et notre
société tout entière est très en danger
mais manifestants qui réclament la
régularisation de tous les travailleurs
sans papiers qui est bien veulent faire
un an de cette cause de la cause des
sans-papiers des migrants et en thème et
qui pèse dans la campagne électorale et
pour ça ils l ont d'ores et déjà prévu
de retourner de manifester de nouveau
dans la rue en dans les semaines et les
mois à venir
merci un adage 1 pour toutes ces
précisions